but this is going to be really tough to
see so how are we going to actually
determine what the right answer is if I
were to drop it now it would happen so
fast you wouldn't really see clearly
what's happening so I've brought along
my slow-motion camera and you'll see it
at 300 frames per second and it's quite
spectacular
well that's ultra slow-mo so that's
exactly what we need to sort out this
problem we'll give a countdown because
what happens really fast all right three
two one
drops wow did you see that I I didn't
really see which happened first no I
need it need to slay that deal let's go
to a slow-motion replay and see what
actually happened
so from the slow-motion camera we can
clearly see that the bottom end stayed
completely stationary even after you you
let go at the top it waited until the
whole slinky had collapsed down to the
bottom before it itself moved downwards
how do we explain that well there are a
number of explanations but the simplest
explanation is that the bottom end is
sitting there minding its own business
with gravity pulling it down and tension
pulling it up equal and opposite forces
no motion at the bottom end until the
bottom end gets the information that the
tension has changed and it takes time
for that information to propagate down
through the slinky to reach the bottom
and so it's propagating down as a
compressional wave and we saw that
compression wave traveled down and it
has to reach the bottom before the
bottom even knows that you've let go at
the top correct and that's when he knows
to start falling correct that's a really
remarkable finding I mean does this
apply to any other objects or is it just
slinkys now it applies to the real world
particularly in sports which is the
field I'm interested in for example when
a player hits a ball there's a huge
force at the business end but that force
is not felt at the handle in until that
the ball is well on its way so that a
wave has to propagate from the business
end down to the handle end and then a
propagates back again and what you
actually feel down this end is
considerably less than what the ball
felt so wow if you're playing tennis or
something you only feel that you've hit
the ball after you've actually hit the
ball in the balls
nearly to the net by the time you
actually feel what's happened that goes
against you know all your intuitions
that you really can feel it as soon as
the balls on your on your racquet ah
it's the same in golf if you work a golf
ball you often find golfers will finish
with a nice flourish thinking that it
has some effect on the ball but of
course the ball was halfway to the hole
by the time that happens of course now
what if we wanted to do a little
extension activity I want you to make a
prediction if we attach this
tennis ball onto the base of the slinky
and we drop it again what will happen to
the tennis ball will it do the same as
the base of the slinky and just stay
there
or will it fall with the acceleration
due to gravity G or will it go upwards
whoa I have to try it and find out all
right I'd like you to make a prediction
now quick